right now the brexit voyage is looking
really rather choppy and some
influential MPs are seeking safe haven
here in Norway at Oslo municipal Porter
wealthy European nation formerly out of
the European Union in control of its own
fishing waters and borders the Norway
option a way to take the post brexit
dive with a controlled descent and the
backup of an existing inside the Osmo
Parliament MPs acknowledge that Norway
can't always dance to its own tune the
Norwegian option staying in the European
Economic Area by rejoining the European
free trade association was derided
during the referendum campaign as facts
democracy
you had the fax machine actually the
base machine doesn't they exist those
are the golden doors to your Union to
Parliament if it's a sovereign
Parliament doesn't do you know you're
not like controlled by the EU well in in
some ways we are controlled by the EU in
the energy also in the finance and some
other areas well we are controlled by
the European Union that surprised with
paying for access to the single market
say pro-eu Norwegian MPs there is a
heavy dose of skepticism about the kind
of bedfellow the UK would be should it
we join the club it originally helped to
found in the interest of the British
people the EEA agreement would be a
great agreement to be in but for us in
the after after countries having a
partner that is only there for a short
time that will is so much bigger than us
it's not necessarily in our interest
surely in this difficult brexit
negotiations in everybody's interest
that the UK comes to some sort of
compromise and doesn't fall out over
situation I don't want after to be the
rebound partner that the UK comes to
after breaking up with the EU and I'm
pretty sure that's not in the norwegian
self-interest
two years ago at the beginning of the
brexit process Sky News traveled to
Luxembourg to see for itself the f2
court that arbitrates on behalf of EEE a
even then some cabinet ministers were
mooting membership as a sensible
compromise option it certainly could be
a transitional arrangements for the
United Kingdom the question would then
be whether it would be fair you know to
use the other effort estates for this
purpose so the government of the UK
should not be ruling out this this
option I would say would be unreasonable
two years on and the f2 option has
emerged on the front line of the debate
here in Norway they're not under the
direct jurisdiction of the European
Court of Justice and they do have more
powers domestically than EU states over
fisheries over some aspects of freedom
of movement the Prime Minister of the
United Kingdom has decided that this
Norway option is not a valid
interpretation of the referendum results
but is unequivocally true that Norway is
not a member of the European Union and
intriguingly members of our own party
are looking at this option certainly the
Icelandic foreign minister was making
positive noises when Sky News caught up
with him in Oslo no it's not the same as
the EU says a minister who's been busy
signing trade deals as mrs. may has been
trying to do the same hello minister
it's faisal hey how you doing I'm doing
good look eea is a very good option for
nations who want to make their own free
trade deals have access to the EU market
and only pay a small portion
the fee the you countries need to pay
into the EU budget there are number of
MPs and a number of cabinet ministers
privately who think that this could make
a plan B if UK want to join after the
agreement we would look at them into
that very positively but it is on
Norway's nearly frictionless border with
Europe that Mrs May has drawn her
redline an end to free movements if the
members do have some extra immigration
powers a growing number in Parliament
feel that following Norway and Iceland
into after may be the only way out of
the coming constitutional crisis puzzle
Islam Sky News in Oslo